welcome
[Applause]
woo
hello one two one two we are the lake
town spy Network how you doing
ComicCon quick go tell the master of
Lake town that The Hobbit panel is is
about to begin Swift boy
run
[Music]
[Applause]
hello if I could only go back in time
and show this to my 13-year-old
self welcome to today's panel on Hobbit
Battle of Five Armies and a celebration
of Peter Jackson's move Middle Earth the
battle for six
movies my name is Steven coar and if you
were anything like
me you don't just love these stories you
treasure the world of JRR
tolken let me take you to a Time long
ago an earlier age the time of Clinton
the dark days of dialup Internet
a rumor came to us that director Peter
Jackson would be making an adaptation of
the trilogy at the time many of us knew
him only from his movie Heavenly
Creatures and as great as that movie
is I wasn't sure there was room for
hysterical murderous teenage girls in
Middle
Earth other than of course
Ean I was worried that somehow he would
take away my treasure my horde of
precious Middle Earth stories it was a
very possessive obsessive very dragony
feeling so I found and followed
everything I could about the progress of
these movies I remember seeing the
first stills from the filming of Helms
Deep I looked at every casting
announcement I scoured the work of John
how and alen Lee I read the online
debates about fantasy versus fairy tales
and I began to have hope not just hope
the movies would be good I was given
hope that
finally finally people might not roll
their eyes when I started talking about
Middle
Earth that my head full of facts from
fenor to farer might suddenly have some
social value that someone might say to
me Hey Stephen you know a lot about
tolken can you explain something to me
and I would say yes oh God yes I
will and then the movies broke upon the
world and to steal a line from CS Lewis
Here were beauties that pierced like
swords or burned like cold iron here
were movies that would break your heart
good Beyond
hope and rather than taking away our
treasure Peter and Fran Walsh and Philip
aboyans and Richard Taylor and Grant
major and Dan Hannah and the cast and
the crew and wetted digital and the land
and the people of New Zealand itself
added to our stories complemented our
imagination the only problem as I saw it
was that at a total running time of 11
and 1 half hours they were too damn
[Applause]
short I feel I feel this must be how
Orlando Bloom feels all the
time we wanted
more and though we had to wait nearly a
decade our patience was rewarded with a
cast and creative team we love and trust
and we were invited back to hobbiton to
Rivendell across the Misty Mountains
Cold to through water wood and hill by
Reed and Willow to finally come face to
face with the beautiful but dangerous
silver tongue villain of The
Hobbit the lake down
spy I just hope I fulfilled Professor
tolan's
Vision I have a question to start off
for for everyone on stage right now do
you get that everywhere you go at this
point or just everywhere in San
Diego Peter how how are you me yes uh
I'm very good thank you Stephen thank
you very much for coming well on behalf
uh on behalf of myself and everyone here
and all the fans around the world over
the last how many years now since the
first movie came out 13 yeah thank you
something something like that yeah thank
you very much for making these movies
thank you're very welcome thank
you I do um I do I do have to send
apologies from Martin and Ian and
Richard who would all love to be here
but um
Martin and Richard are on stage in
London and unable to get away and no
yeah Ian shooting a movie that's right
yes that's what's happening isn't it yes
but uh but they do send their love and
um I'm sure you'll see them again
sometime on some of project so Peter are
you done with the last movie yet uh no
no we're still working um we are
uh we I mean the creation of the movie
never really stops and so what we're
doing at the moment I
it's editing but it's a lot more than
editing because we because we are um
we've we've got Bal sequences to do um
and a lot of other you know rather
intricate things and so we're doing
motion capture for that um or we're
doing animation you know in the case of
some of the big creatures and and we're
uh and so I'm supervising that then that
goes on to the motion capture stage then
I go on with a virtual camera and I film
it which I absolutely love doing so I'm
still shooting the movie in essence they
haven't they haven't stopped me filming
it yet um
and shoot a big battle I think we have
6,000 extras who might be able to
join I know they would be good too
wouldn't they they'd know they'd know
what to
do well let me ask you something about
how the the movies are made as you said
you're doing a lot of this motion
capture and going into the digital
environment with a camera to capture
things the people who've worked together
on stage have
is this the first time some of you have
met here at Comic Con even though you've
done the movie
together yes some of us yeah yeah yes
have any of you ever been in scenes
together and never met
before yes yeah
who and Kate yeah we we worked together
and I I I didn't meet Kate until well
after I'd finished working with her
really seems to be my run of
things wow wow did either of you
complain that the other person was
stealing feeling focused she took ages
to come out of her trailer and you know
you had that big long I kept eating your
snacks and I was in your way all the
time yeah it was
yeah kind of amazing Peter when you
started back in 19 was it 1995 when you
first started about doing these movies
um yeah 95 or 96 I think some sometime
like that so by the time this film is
released once it's released and still
it'll still be running in 19 uh in 2015
you will have spent 20 years thinking
about this world did you imagine that
this was going to take a generation of
your
life and is that a happy thing for me to
say um well it's a commitment isn't it
really it's a commitment um but no I I
and it's a commitment I already have
already enjoyed taking it's been a you
know you never you never know what's
going to happen next I mean the very
first thing that we ever pitched to
mirax back in '95 was it was um to make
The Hobbit as a single movie and if that
was successful we'd do two Lord of the
Rings movies that that was the pitch
that was what we you know well sort of
things went a bit differently didn't
they really but but um but you know wait
it was originally pitched to be two
movies yeah well The Hobbit was going to
be we were going to shoot The Hobbit
first it was one movie and then if that
was successful we would do Lord of the
Rings back toback two movies and that
was the pitch to MX that that was the
original pitch and so I you know that
was you so everything just changes it's
organic so you it's I mean it's not what
it would be really boring if it was 20
years where you had it all laid out you
knew exactly what was going to happen
and you were just ticking the boxes but
it certainly it's it's an adventure
every step of it's an adventure I I do
want to complain to you again as I have
before that since the Hobbit which is
one book became three movies technically
you owe us six more movies for the
[Laughter]
trilogy sure if Warners could find a way
to do that they would they would
certainly be very
happy
uh Elijah yes sir hello good
[Applause]
see hope that you're here doing this
this is amazing yeah it is it is no I I
realized that why why don't you
age and Peter did you know you are
casting The
Immortal I don't know maybe I have a
painting in my attic that's Aging for me
yes it kind of go the same thing also
goes for the elves I mean
uh Orlando and
Kate I don't know what creams they're
putting down on you but darling I want
some that's a good idea we should come
out with one shouldn't we an Elvin face
cream I do have as a fan I do have a
question for the elves people who played
elves in the movie so um since elves are
uh Immortal you can call us elves we
like it you you like don't have to
distinguish between people who played
elves and people who are
elves
you might be an
elf do do elves do you have to think
differently or are you thinking as a
human do you have to put yourself in the
mind of an immortal when you do this do
you have pity on the rest of your cast
members when you're in character yes I
was I was typ cast
yes no they're incredibly generous I
look I was dis grateful to get a job in
this one I I thought my time was over in
Middle Earth so yeah you and me
both
are elves generous do you mean or have
Peter been generous to bring you back
what do you mean uh a bit a bit of both
okay no but I do I do think gadriel is
incredibly um generous yeah it was a big
stretch for
me just to get you out of the trailer
you
exactly now Peter can we talk about the
tone of the movies when when um the
trilogy of The Hobbit was announced my
understanding is that the tone of the
movie movies would sort of progress
toward the tone of The Lord of the Rings
movies the sort of match up when you
watch them all together um how would you
say the tone has changed from the first
movie from an Unexpected Journey to
desolation of smog and how's that
extended in this
movie well it's I mean I think it's
extended the way that you would imagine
it would extend seeing the first two
it's it's a progression and it's
certainly um I probably just about
everybody in this room knows what's
going to happen at the end of The Hobbit
never mind um you know there are there
are there's s a lot of sadness and
tragedy and um you know which is good
it's always great when you can kill kill
off some main characters I'll tell you
what it's like as a filmmaker thank God
like when you can finally kill
somebody um because it gives you a
chance to do something you know
hopefully that's powerful and emotional
and uh otherwise you're a little bit I
mean it's it's so anyway we we um we do
get to kill a few of them this time
around so it's good and um I think
you'll you you'll feel it getting quite
quite yeah well I mean dark dark isn't
the word I mean the I mean these are fun
movies fun you know even I mean the
Rings movies were fun I don't think
they're just you know but the yes it's
not as comical as the first um Hobbit
movie for sure and they're progressively
getting towards the um the tone of the
Fellowship of the Ring do you know
Elijah was 18 years old when we did
Fellowship by the way I was just was
trying to work that out and he's still
18 years
old philipo as one of the screenwriters
when having the the luxury of telling
the story over three movies instead of
one do you wish you'd had been able to
include more things in the first two
movies me in the first three movies if
if you had had this sort of pace of
Storytelling that you have in The Hobbit
as opposed to Lord of the Rings are
there things that you guys wish you
could have put in the first three movies
that you had to take out just for a time
yeah you mean in in Lord of the Ring
yeah sure say Tom I think of them as a
continuation well yeah of course the Old
Forest definitely and Tom I I um did you
think about Tom Bombadil at all did you
consider about we did we did we had a
Pete had some very funny ideas including
um seeing his uh hat while they were on
the road do you remember that we
actually wrote that into the script um
uh but uh no that will have to be for uh
another generation of filmmakers I
suspect mhm did you have anyone in mind
for the
cast for Bombadil no but can I tell you
that we we did do a wish list I remember
and and and it's sitting in a box
somewhere Pete keeps everything and um
on that wish list was uh a young
Australian actress for gadriel called
Kate Blanchet that was our absolute
number one no this is true and then but
I had Kate in in a wish list in a box
somewhere Bombadil no no no no
for no that was our first our first list
of of possible people for for casting I
see right well Benedict you're playing
the ultimate heavies
you're playing the ultimate Heavies in
this movie sorry you're playing the
ultimate Heavies in this movie playing
you're playing saurin and you're playing
the dragon yeah how would you how would
you how would you characterize the
difference between these two bad
guys one's a dragon all right someone
have a pen I'd like to write that down
take this down you need to know this
one's a dragon and one's an
allseeing non
Corporal entity of
evil yes did I go away with it no one
screen rubbish um no it's yeah one's
real one's made of something that's
vulnerable and one seems to be born out
of everything that's evil and and
difficult to pin down and actually kill
is there any is there any uh benefit to
doing the motion capture that you hadn't
experienced before um as an actor is
there something that motion capture
gives you absolutely get standard free
to just make a complete fool of yourself
and lose yourself in your imagination
and not you don't have to hit it's much
harder what these guys did with green
screen acting opposite pingpong balls
and marks of tape and pretending that's
your reality in the whole costume with
continuity taking into account camera
moves I was just throwing myself around
a carpeted floor like a lunatic um and
Andy did you have any advice for him did
did did what was the do you have any
advice for benedict on how to do motion
capture just to make sure you don't get
carpet Burns really
yeah put the velcro in the right places
exactly yeah Benedict thank you they
love you Benedict Graham as as as as uh
dwalin yes as
[Music]
[Applause]
dwalin do you think that the dwarves get
enough credit in this movie for being
Heroes because they're not the most
obviously sexy creatures in the world
well obviously to the female dwarves
we're very very sexy are there female
dwarves there are well i' I've often
thought that the entire journey is is
Seeking a female
dwarf and uh boy it takes us a long time
but um no it's it's nice to be the only
representative of my race here today um
I feel a little outnumbered by my Elvin
compatriots but uh yeah no it's been
it's been an extraordinary experience
being um being a dwarf when you're 6 fo
three
so um that alone that alone was two and
a half years I'll never
[Laughter]
forget uh
Luke can you actually shoot a bow did
you know how to do that before you took
the job uh ye yes yes yeah I where did
you learn were you a Boy Scout um no no
I did it in um Butlins but no one know
what that is it's a very it's a very
workingclass holiday Resort and I went
with my family as kids and that's what
we used to do we used to archery but no
I mean when we got to when I got to New
Zealand um I really did it properly then
and used a very very big bow that was
much bigger than me and um arrows that
were very very large and um yeah I could
probably do it we did have it actually
do a day it's a shame cuz I think aen
Turner remembers a day when we were all
shooting cuz the dwarves used to shoot
from the hip and I used to shoot from
the face and whatever and we had to
aimim at these little action men that
they' put on the wall and um and I did
it I got it I beat
[Music]
them Kate as an elf uh we haven't had a
chance to see you fight that's one of
the things that the elves do better than
anyone else they're the ninjas of Middle
Earth are we going to be able to see you
fight this time do you have a weapon
well I I actually in the High School
production of of The Hobbit which you
did I actually played The Bard so I I
was sort of prepared for a bit of
fighting but as an elf you have to wear
because you're very tall I'm relatively
tall but not that tall I had to wear
these sort of hugely High sort of disco
Glam boots which were so it's a little
bit tricky to even walk so underneath
that gown you've got disco heels on
you've got disco heels on under the
under the Gown not but just for height
we do we do get to see
gadriel losing it a little bit in this
next movie was good it's a bit judgment
yeah I lose my is that what you're
about to say
yeah Elvin
sure I'm sure it's Sparkles she
does she gets to kick zon's ass a little
in this next film
so Philipa have you recovered from me
smoking you in the tolken trivia contest
in the August of
2010 have you saw therapy from me
crushing you no but um I was uh I it was
very touching because your very
beautiful wife came up afterwards and
said I think this is the greatest night
of his
life Peter chall Peter challenged me to
a trivia contest with Philippa and um
and I won and I won and it was and I as
I said to you you don't understand I was
I'm a I'm an athlete who's been training
his entire life for a race he never knew
was coming I I think it might have been
a little closer than you remember
though
we could we could remount the challenge
for charity do you do you remember what
what you won on what was the winning
answer do you
remember no but I do remember um when
Steven fry said oh you've really got the
crowd on your side um is when you asked
me who uh goldberry was oh yeah yeah you
actually asked me what goldberry was not
who goldberry was oh did I I think I'd
he just kind of tripped me up with the
old River daughter answer you know what
was really funny cuz it was it was me
and Steven and we were asking each other
questions so I think nobody else in the
room knew whether we were getting them
right or wrong well that that was in the
final round stepen fry and I designed
questions for the two of you to start
with and and then then you guys ended up
just when when you when it all got a
little bit crazy at the end you guys
just started firing really hard ones at
at each at each other and we and none of
us really knew clear notes right well
the Clincher for me was when you asked
me goldberry and I put my head on the
table and everyone thought I didn't know
what the answer was but I was just
trying to think of the first line of the
poem and so I raised my head and said oh
slender as a willow wand oh clearer than
clear water oh lead by the Liverpool
Fair River daughter oh Springtime and
summertime and spring again after a wind
on the waterfall and the leaves
laughter and stepen fr said you've
really got them on your side
now I think probably nor normally
winners normally winners are very modest
aren't
they I'll never have this opportunity
again now uh I I've noticed that there
is a difference in in class in elom and
Orlando
[Music]
um your father does not want you to date
down perhaps the two of you could
address this is there a social is there
a social message in in this movie yes
I'm a class elf is that what you want me
to say you want me to Adit it to the
world class trashy elf but my still
[Laughter]
Sparkles was that on your resume is that
how you got the
gig that was on their wish list we've
heard of Angeline Lily's Sparkles
we like her as an
elf um well Peter I think uh based on
the time I think maybe we've um where
are we we're at uh we're at uh we're
we're okay we could do okay
another five five minutes or or 10
minutes of questions all right have you
have you run run out of questions any of
the actors here any of the actors here
I'd like to ask about your experience in
New Zealand you know Lee for instance
had you been to New Zealand
before no i' never I'd never been before
but I absolutely made the most of it I
love being outside and hiking and stuff
and you can't find a better place for
that than New Zealand like awesome
awesome hikes really really fun I've had
I a feeling when I went we went down
there again Peter invited us down very
kindly my wife and my two boys and I
were extras and we spent two weeks down
there I had a strong feeling that I
should never leave New Zealand you know
it was like this is where I will be a
man yeah I know you know what I mean it
really calls to you it says if you are
you as raw as this mountain is could you
carve out a life plus no
bears that's right no snakes does
anybody have any particular anybody do
want any Adventure travel down there
because there are a lot of ways to kill
yourself not being killed by an animal
in New Zealand did anybody take
advantage of any of this sort of
Adventure I went up um I went I went H I
can say this now cuz I'm out of contract
but I did go up a glacia while I was uh
down there you didn't tell any helic us
up to the middle of the fox glaci here
and then left us there for a few hours
brilliant and we went through ice caves
and yeah and then me and Aiden jumped
out of an airplane as well at one point
you did that did it's the sort of
country where you can do a lot about
jumping I jumped out of things jumped
off things anything I could get thrown
out of or off I would pretty much do
dando did you did you move down there
for any period of time like three years
yeah I mean after the movie was over I
understood you st you stay Stayed for a
while I was no I've sort of come and
gone a bit but it's sort of it's funny
actually because there was an email
exchange between me and Dom and Elijah
just two days ago talking about getting
residency in New Zealand Don was like we
realized more compated than we we
thought yeah
yeah oie oie throws himself off anything
and with a bungee on it's like I mean
I'm I'm
believable did any of you come to the
stories uh of uh the Lord of the Rings
and The Hobbit for the first time
through the films and did it make you
then go back to the books or did you say
to hell with it I'm never going to read
them any Elijah did you go back and read
the books I actually haven't truth be
told I still haven't read the books
Never I know what I'm getting Christmas
listen I've said this before get out of
here I'm
okay I'm okay elah do you know how to
read I do do cuz you've been in show
business since were a child I read The
Hobbit when I was a child and it was a
big big book for me um and I had the
Lord of the Rings on my shelf and it was
one of those things that was very
daunting and was kind of always there
and I thought I'll get to that one day
and then these movies came about and I
sort of I felt like I was living it and
experienced it in such a profoundly deep
way that I I never really consulted the
books I imagine it's something that I
will go back to but I don't know it was
such an experience over the course of
such a long period of time I I loved
reading Lord of the Rings so much when I
was young that um when I got about 25
pages to the end of Return of the King I
took my book and I reverently closed it
and I said I will never read those pages
because this story must go
on and I have never read those pages
that's beautiful ever
wow no evangelene is a serious geek a
serious talking geek wow no no no I love
love love love token but I don't know
squat like I can't remember the names
the places so I fail every token geek
test don't try but I love him oh he's so
disappointed no he's ready to I'm not
disappointed at all actually you've
never been more
attractive
what do you think of my hair should I
keep
this really
fantastic a uh Andy hello tell me tell
me about
your tell me about the work tell us all
about the work you're doing in London
now with your
company wow uh well look I mean it's
been an extraordinary uh 15 years when
uh when Peter asked me to to come when I
met Peter and Fran in London uh back in
1999 I think it was um and and the idea
of of playing this creature Golem came
up H and and there wasn't like an exact
method of how it was going to be done
and but but basically Peter wanted an
actor to come on set and be there and
play the character and not have Elijah
and sha have to imagine someone um it
basically changed the course of my life
to S with such magnitude um of course
you know it Not only was it about
finding a way of bringing that character
that a screen but also creating a
methodology of work which again you know
then went on I mean actually I have to
say the Epiphany for me of of of of kind
of where where I'm at today came
immediately in the last uh weeks of
doing Return of the King because on my
birth it was the 20th of April and I
think it was 2003 the last pickups for
for for Return of the King and it was my
it was my birthday and Peter asked me on
on that day it was literally right at
the end of the pickups to to to play
King Kong and I realized I've just I've
thought my life was going to go back to
normality to play normal characters in
normal films in a normal traditional way
and uh and then and then then the idea
it sort of hit me overnight hold on a
minute I've just played this 3 and 1/2t
ring junkie and now I'm going to now I'm
going to play a 25 foot gorilla wow this
means typ casting is no more you know
this means you can do anything you can
put on one pair of spandex suits and um
go and enjoy yourself on the carpet and
uh play play any any manner of things
and and that kind of Fascination and
enjoyment really has continued over the
years and most of which has been been
again involved with Peter and and
learning with WETA who are the most
fantastic amazing bunch of people to
work with
Incredible you know and and you know
it's it's a it's a sort of knowledge
base and a and a skill set and uh which
I which I love and adore and I do think
philosophically as an actor it does
break down so many barriers you can play
anything you know any whatever you are
it doesn't matter you can play anything
um and and WETA they the incredible and
the work that they have continued to do
uh in the facial Pipeline and and you
know going back to play Golem the second
time and seeing how that had all moved
on and how the performances are really
beautifully rendered now and very
truthful to what what happens on the set
between the director and so on and it's
it's been a fantastic amazing
unbelievable journey of which of course
I never had any I had I couldn't foresee
coming at all and and and it's ended up
with being in a position where very very
luckily now I'm trying to bring it to
the Northern Hemisphere because I
realized it doesn't actually exist in
the northern hemisphere uh in it's
particularly in Europe so we have a a
place called The Imaginarium which is
sort of I I see as a sort of uh you know
Northern Hemisphere uh T touch base for
for for anyone who's who's happening to
be doing OE from New Zealand who wants
to drop by and work there so um it's
it's it's a great it's a great time
really enjoying it and you know and it's
very much down to to to Peter and Fran
and philipper and all the incredible
experience I have had well thank you
you touched on something you touched on
something that I think is really
interesting you said you thought you'd
be going back to normal films after
doing this but I think after certainly
after the first three films what it
meant to make a norval film had changed
and the work that you did actually sort
of as the the lawn chainy of the digital
world is to change what could be done on
screen and for Peter and his and his
team to change um what well for one
thing what spectacle means in a movie
certainly after the battle of the pner
fields in the third movie I said
immediately after the battle's over
nothing can ever be called spectacle
again without first being compared to
this event and so um how do you think do
you see the change that's happened in
film like every battle of two PE two
people clashing like close shots of
people clashing in a battle on screen
these days looks something like it's an
echo of that dagger lad battle at the
beginning of the prologue for the first
Fellowship in the ring everything's got
that that russan that Clash feeling that
just didn't exist before do do you see
your work being
echoed I I did a little bit yeah I did
recognize some B the sort of style and
some films that came through in in you
know in the in the Years following but I
mean that's amazing I mean as a
filmmaker there's no better compliment
than to feel that you've you know you've
influenced the the way in which other
filmmakers you know the tools that they
can use in the way that they might might
want to shoot their movies so yeah it's
um yeah I've got I'm in the middle of
doing a battle right now actually big
battle Battle of Five Armies it's
um
Kate gladel is kissing on Gandalf in
there what's going
on it's it's an ancient Love Story it
was actually born um the first time
around I was so sad um because I you
know I adore Ian as does everyone here
that I hardly got to do anything with
him at all why I mean anything at all um
and well no because I I mean I in the
first story it was just it was glancing
Oh you mean in the first one of course
you don't first time around backwards
and so it was so special and and also
having worked with Hugo so intensely on
stage over the last 10 years to sort of
10 years later to go back and then you
know all the core story because of
course gladel just a footnote in in in
The Hobbit really um to have such a
beautiful loving um Rel relationship of
understanding did you wear any of the
original costume did they bring any
costum I you said did I wear
underwear no but my elves don't figurine
didn't have my boys were horrified cuz
they weren't born the first time around
to see the the figurines and the elves
didn't in fact wear underwear so I
didn't but that wasn't what you going
that's a bit that was a bit too much
sharing
there I think I I think you buried the
lead on that story no did you wear any
of the original costumes from the first
three movies in in The Hobbit movie no
it was all well I think the crown was
the same but it was all it was all kind
of rebooted and revamped but of a theme
you know I wasn't W wearing trousers did
we did did um did we use any original
cost Elijah did you you didn't we you
know I don't think it was an actual
original I think it was a remake I mean
we T we tend to keep the original
costumes there sort of sacred now so we
we kind of don't put don't get sweat in
them again um you know there's I mean
we're hoping to do a lot a museum one
day where we can have all the stuff on
display so um so we we you know we
didn't really want to trash the the Lord
of the Rings stuff for for The Hobbit
generally so we tended to make new stuff
new I did have my wig my wig was the
same yeah my wig was the same my wig was
the same yeah we had two wigs from Lord
of the Rings and we were your ears
different my ears were well your ears
Contin to grow you had the same ear they
had to rec they had to rec wait a second
your ears didn't fit anymore no he was
grow
his ears to try and get them to be half
as beautiful as Tel's big pointy
ears we have an ear thing sorry Terio
was obsessed with having really big
Point ear and I was like I think they
should be a little subtler than that
honey but she was like no I'm I'm going
all the way on this ear I know how sexy
a big pointy ear can
be but they were a bit more aerodynamic
this time around I felt yeah but you can
only say that in retrospect I I mean you
know um Peter speaking of saving things
from The Lord of the Rings one of the
things that people may not know is that
you've got these huge warehouses in
Wellington with all the old well they
know they know now don't
they sorry sorry our secret warehouses
yes no right yeah it was just one of the
greatest experiences of my life was to
walk through yeah the Misty Mountains
yes Misty Mountains uh you know uh go to
minth to stand in a tower over minth or
Rivendell or to actually take a quick
look to really take a look at what you
had at the grey Havens CU in the movie
you don't get to see any the mountain
the No No The Haven beautiful miniature
it's a beautiful miniature and as you
say it was never really seen so yeah
it's an incred it's incredible beautiful
yeah but we just yeah I mean we've got
it all we've kept it all and so you know
we've kept it all for a reason I want to
try to to let people see it one day so
more than just you I mean it was nice
having you there Steven but it' be nice
to have these folk there as well so
[Applause]
one thing that you don't see in the
movie I don't know whether you took it
out digitally but when I went and looked
at Grand when you have grand the like
the the it's like the 12 foot long
version of grand there the the Warhammer
that knocks down the gates of minth is
that it's a wolf you know a ravening
wolf with fire coming out of its mouth
but the prop itself has a
penis the wolf that you made it's a
penis and it's got a very it's very
sharp it's kind of a
terrifying image how do you know the
wolf's penis is sharp did you touch it
yes he did he did I'm a I'm a super
fan I I mean I never actually realized
it until until you you pointed it
[Laughter]
out but no it wasn't it wasn't removed I
mean no one ever asked us to remove it
in the film you remove it no must be
there somewhere it's there Stephen it's
because of people like you running
around and touching wolves penises that
ComicCon is a scary place to
be all right got yeah questions you
ready to do some fan questions yeah
everybody out there we've got
microphones and let's see where are they
right over here where the light
is and the young woman wearing the armor
of
buttons it's a very effective suit of
wow yes
this this is the Lord of the Rings cape
and Hobbit Cape everything on here is
Lord of Rings Hobbit um in 10 years I
expect to be back here uh watching clips
from the
Similan uh first things first in dragon
voice Benedict could you say button
lady Buton
lady
sorry I hadn't warmed up thank you my
question that was great um my question
is for uh a couple of the elves we've
seen that two shot of Bard and legalis
my question is does legalis teach Bard
about archery or does Bard teach legalis
about ar oh whoa o I like the way you're
going with
that we have a bow off yeah we have a
bow off you did get to kill the dragon I
suppose do you want the sensible answer
or do you want a silly answer silly
answer oh I don't
know I don't know well did you have
taught me everything I know I've seen
your archery
skills the truth is both of these guys
are particularly good at archery in real
life and so they're both sort of quietly
I think thinking how do I tell them I'm
really
but this guy's okay but I'm really
good yes yes yes he's got longer arrows
and a bigger bow but not quite as good a
shot is that a
metaphor until the last moment sorry oh
my arrows are
sharp and very
long bit like that Wolf's penis
okay yeah buddy your question firstly to
Mr Jack and to everyone involved in
these thank you very much for bringing
these supera epic movies out bringing
these to life forever thank you you're
very welcome um my question my my
children Logan and Olivia wanted me to
ask this to Mr Lee but he's not here but
perhaps the cast could answer who do you
think is more evil soran or Mr Wonka
from the Wily Wonka
movies from the Willy Wonka movie Willy
Wonka is not
evil Willie Wonka is a
master no Mr Wonka the gentleman who
kept the son in that races and let him
leave the house at age 10 and all
the you got her there
bro stumped don't often see that I will
uh I'll pass that question on to Chris
Lee when I when I talk to him
next um the young
goddess
hi uh I'm a huge fan of tolken and Lord
of the Rings and The Hobbit and I'm also
very interested in the technical aspects
of acting so I was wondering to all the
actors on the panel if you had any
specific technical um techniques that
you used in order to get into character
especially considering that sometimes
you don't actually have an actor to play
off
of
Andy Andy Andy
I don't know why everybody's looking at
me I Andy Circus has been voted the
answer of that question uh well you know
the fact of the matter is that that
although there's technology involved in
in the way of creating characters I can
only speak from my point of view of
characters like golum really what it is
is exactly the same all you need the all
you need is the eyes of another actor to
look into and that's it you know people
attach this whole kind of mystery to
Performance capture really the magic is
having bril actors together in a room or
on a set or in an environment and being
able to play off each other and not let
the technology become a part of it that
really is the key so it's about you know
embodying the character as you would in
a in a very normal way despite the fact
that you're only wearing a spandex suit
um you know any any of that stuff is
just about client you know losing the
ability to lose yourself in a world to
lose yourself in a character to bury
yourself in a part so deep that that you
believe that that you're you're that
person or whatever I mean that the the
technical aspects are challenging in in
movies like this there's there's no
question but but I don't think anyone
any one of these anyone anybody on this
stage really would let that get in the
way of what what it's really about and I
think that's the key yeah well it's like
layers of imagination we've got token's
imagination and then our imagination
comes in and then the CGI comes on top
of that and it's like all of these kind
of beautiful collaborations you know one
on top of each other but if everyone's
imagination is kind of alive I think the
movie it's cool yeah know
yeah I think it also must be said that I
mean Benedict was talking about working
to a tennis ball or or green screen and
certainly in the first movies I had no
idea how to play an elf and unlike any
director I think I've ever worked with
Peter and and and also philipper and
Fran before every scene would absolutely
as if this was a piece of naturalism
describe what had happened before that'
show you pictures drawings um things
plates that already shot of what you
were looking at the atmosphere that you
were in so even though there were fans
going and wind blowing and people
covered in dots and we half Prosthetics
you were completely invited into the
given circumstances of the world as as
if you know you doing check off kind of
with prosthetic ears and
Boots yes hello uh this questions to Lee
Andy um Benedict and maybe the rest of
the cast if you had to take the
characters that you played to attend
comic K uh where would you take them and
why whole H I don't think I'd fit in
anywhere
[Applause]
else was
it be a bit of a squeeze I don't know
I'd ride my elk right up that aisle
right
[Applause]
there oh I left I left it in New Zealand
I don't have it with me let's move on to
the next question I asked Andy as well
so
um well I don't know where where I'd go
but Gollum would probably um go well why
don't we ask him and see where he'd go
[Applause]
um well my secret
dream precious yes what is it well I
would quite like to
go backstage with Steven C
and see what he's got inside his costume
precious
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes yes the young man surrendering
greatest I'm a Navy SEAL with over 300
confirmed
kills oh my God I have an actual
question
um when
you when you guys were uh working like
on The Hobbit like all three of them um
were you I I mean this both but were you
guys thinking of doing this more as a as
its own film or as a prequel to L of the
Rings question um Philipa uh it's
interesting because we we did make the
decision to to use um the appendices and
and uh from The Lord of the Rings so we
knew it was going to be set against that
backdrop um so it did shift it of course
from the children's novel which it which
it clearly was written to be by
Professor talking but what's cool about
that is we do get
to go places that you know about in the
novel but uh happened but uh happen you
know Gandalf leaves the company we get
to follow him we get to see what happens
and and dogor and we get to see the
white Council go up against Sauron so
that kind of stuff makes it really cool
really fun yeah it's um you know when
when tolken wrote The Hobbit in 1937 it
was just written as his a book that he
wrote in you know in the absence of any
any other Middle Earth material that
stage but of course The Hobbit movie is
different because The Hobbit movies is
coming out on the after the Lord of the
Rings film so we we we coming at from a
different direction than talkling did he
sort of worked his way up and we're kind
of working our way down the other
direction really to sort of to um to
blend them but um I mean I've always
wanted to just make them work as a six
film set that's what I that I mean with
the the goal going in at the beginning
was to try to get the the The Hobbit and
to be the
tonally to be going into Fellowship
which then ultimately ends with Return
of the King so I've been always just
thinking of the Six film sort of you
know box DVD said except by the time
it's finished probably won't be any DVDs
anymore but never mind it was um it's a
shame but um the Six film downloads does
not not very good at it not what what's
cool about it though is you do get some
you know some people are going to watch
this from the beginning they they have
never seen it they get to start with a
hobbit and go go all the way through and
and you mentioned uh galadriel's
relationship with gandal so when you get
to fellowship and legalist says he
fell and you're reaction to that is
going to have a whole new meaning I
think now once you see what they go
through in doal door yeah there's a I
mean there's a there's a generation we
we meet a lot of people that have got
young kids who they they they're taking
them to The Hobbit films they've never
seen the Rings films and they're going
to see the third Hobbit movie and then
they're going to show them the Rings
movies so there's a generation now
that's going to that that is going to be
the way that they're going to think of
these these films okay I think we have
good time for one more question
here
oh God K blanchet's look okay hi um I am
a huge fan of the extended editions as I
think most people are here
um but you know over the years there's
all this rumor of there's more footage
out there we haven't seen is it going to
be in the big six disc set um how are we
going to see an even longer cut of Lord
of the Rings down the road or have we
seen the defin version of those original
Three
films good
question um well yeah I I mean there
there is a few scenes that haven't been
seen from The Lord of the Rings um but
not many very very few um what were
those
[Music]
sins I'll tell you one day don't worry
one we just keep that's um it I I mean
there was there was a there was a um aan
and Aragon scene wasn't it when they
were younger and um when they first met
um that vgo and vgo looked like he was
12 years old without the help of
computers it was quite quite amazing um
um but no there there is a few scenes
and and but I I I don't know we might
try to put them back in I mean it's it's
it's not without its issues cuz the Lord
of the Rings was 7 million ft of 35 Bill
film which is sitting in a mountain in
Arizona somewhere I think at the moment
seriously I think that's where I think
that's where Warner Brothers have some
Vault
somewhere a nuclear a nuclear proof
Vault somewhere where all the all the
negative like our SE the S million feet
of our film is sitting at which we'd
have to go and retrieve it so um it's a
big logistical thing which I don't think
anyone's quite got their heads around
but if there's enough um interest from
[Applause]
people maybe they will thank you Steve
and thank you very much for for um for
flying out and doing it thank thank you
very much thank you for bringing my cast
from the thank you and thank you
everybody thank you to the cast and the
creative
[Applause]
team